all right let's talk a little movie news
now you guys ready for this one the
Magnificent Seven they are riding again
yeah we're talking about Chris Pratt
Denzel Washington and the whole gang
this cast ridiculous now this is a
remake more than 50 years after the
original and I tell you these guys had
so much fun making this movie it ought
to be a crime be mark we have 90 horses
500 crewmen we've got hundreds of
stuntmen real dust real eat real sweat a
lot of real blood this is all real stuff
dang it I'm good Chris even went on
Facebook listing all the things you need
to know about the film tops on his list
Denzel
I always kid Chris you know I call him
Jurassic boy he's a very very fine young
man oh just the guy who directed Denzel
to his Oscar and training day is
directing here to Antoine Fuqua he says
stuntmen were lining up for this gig
Tong's
I can't even count how many guys got
shot off but worse it
they were in heaven this bunch really
does represent the face of America no
wouldn't want to be part of a
magnificent seven in this day it was
seven white guys we don't need to see
that anymore oh good we got a Mexican
the classic story has these seven
outlaws and misfits out to save a small
town from the clutches of the evil Peter
Sarsgaard I want something I take it and
look closely that's Vincent D'Onofrio
behind the beer after he needs to take
if all of us are in a scene together
we're just constantly looking at each
other and saying this is so much fun